[Music]
I love singing along like that it really
annoys people yeah this sign especially
no you're not
that's your biggest so soft this is this
is such a not la la da da dee doo sound
like like Adrienne with rocking but doo
doo dee doo doo dee dee do you have that
we find that doo doo don't there once a
dodo dee doo dee doo see how do you get
that raw maybe she was [ __ ] he
literally just said it doo doo dodoo
that was supposed to be this sweet
moment and it's so embarrassing to watch
you turn this rage that all of it yeah
they never supposed to be like a moment
of connection between them yeah yeah fun
couple did you like it I know he has the
video like the whole thing how are you
gonna wake the baby
[ __ ] you light a sleeper is this a [ __ ]
kid the melody wakes him up doo doo doo
doo Frank help them out on this no no
it's Donna doo doo doo doo dodoo dodoo I
should donate dumpkins
Brina script like what why how can i
mess up do you can't make that mistake
with it huh
he's accused too right sixteen-year-old
demons body or bodyguards dead though is
dead oh wow
that's it doo doo dodoo - two toed - I'm
finally taking your time hold on
taking your time arriving in the studio
just up and doing the town's woman here
yeah sure is now that you walked in and
you're wearing an OPA radio shirt you
know how much I like perks did you have
to pay for that or did you get it for
free no I got it for free when they
cleaned out some offices that's a
collector's item sort of kind of
dwindled like the Edsel how do you feel
you feel comfortable that's good on you
yes I got another one oh yeah we're on
there they were oh yeah I should wear
that today do you wear them all the time
no good good yeah I'm enjoying enjoying
myself having fun good for you and this
is great the show with Jimmy four to six
those hours sound very appealing
oh and and for Artie it's it's great cuz
he's just like there have been times
where after fifteen minutes doing the
show he'll tell a joke it kills and then
he goes what do we knock off early knock
off early really like you're shingling
us no we don't knock off early but just
him saying that yeah yeah that was a
good what do we not going early he
really does need somebody saying they
don't know we're still going on we're
still going we've got some gabagool and
sausage it's a car do you work eight
hours a week yeah that's what it is it's
one fifth of what people normally wha
on Wednesday before the show I'm like
we're halfway through our halfway
through the week after four hours we're
halfway through and then we do the other
two and then Thursday and no I'm yeah
we're Tuesday you're halfway there yeah
actually after Tuesday you're right Jose
A to Z we are halfway through our work
week after Tuesday it tested yeah it is
amazing that seems like a fun game about
4:00 p.m.
there have been a couple of times he's
walked in a little tardy we we do have a
a milk carton with his picture on it
that we superimpose on his chair and and
I talked to that until he comes in but
that's that's good he's just so goddamn
funny his stories and stuff that working
with Howard he's got just some really
funny stories about that and and he was
you know a blue-collar guy yeah
construction he was a longshoreman and
and like I got into radio the same way
he did just back doored it in there got
in he gets on the most popular show ever
in the world and it was uh it was a
great run yeah I already got check oh
look what I got oh yeah I know he is
he's that guy and uh just a really nice
guy you know how'd you get the radio
I used to song parodies and I sent two
sent them to radio stations but PLJ in
Connecticut I don't know you're sitting
around first yeah my brother was I do
[ __ ] it's just like you just make him on
your own yeah yeah I had I had a band
with my brother and we used to play all
the clubs on Long Island and we would
throw in these song parodies every so
often and people loved them so I didn't
want about OJ and we could during that
whole thing you might remember yeah
and Obie played it on his show out of
Bab on Long Island and people loved it
he invited us to come in and do it live
yeah and I saw that as a foot in the
door so I didn't shut the [ __ ] up the
whole show just like what am i right I'm
doing impressions I'm doing [ __ ] were
you happy to be there all was I happy to
be there guy
oh my god and then he was like come back
you know come back next week or come
back two days this week
take everything no this was Alan long
island and then he was taping every show
we did and sending him out to other
stations and we got a call from Boston
and I didn't even know he was doing that
and he's like yeah we got an offer to go
to do radio and bust I'm like okay I'm
there it wasn't hard for you to leave
the other career you had yeah yeah
sheetmetal air conditioning and heating
tin knocker I think the the toolbox and
tools might still be somewhere on the
side of 95 where I threw them did you
give two weeks notice properly I did I
did give two weeks notice but two days
in I cut my hand like I always did
you're working with giant razor blades
is what you work with all day long she
was shaving with them so uh it was
terrible and I cut myself one day and I
just went what the [ __ ] am i doing
giving two weeks notice I was like bye
where'd you cut yourself by on my hand
oh it's the worst right right there
right behind uh a lot of cuts in the air
conditioning and heating business yeah
how about you ever get like a piece of
sharp metal that will scrape against
your hand or Jabby with a corner of
piece of sharp metal it yeah a lot of
times there there are these uh there are
these I guess to hold the ceiling up
they put these very very straight wires
that are very sharp at the end and they
hang them there and then when you're
done putting the ductwork up they put
the ceiling up and hold it up with those
wires I was putting some ductwork up
once one of the wires
I pushed up it went right into my arm
like three inches in and and I had to
pull it out it started kind of gushing
and my my boss was like just throw some
duct tape on it we got to get this done
what yeah that's how [ __ ] that's why
at today in my life I work two hours a
day four days a week yes no calluses I
got City hands mr. yeah for putting
lotion on babies high knees
money money your whole life mr. Cooper
yeah yeah I thought I always was a scary
part about touching metal to me is the
eye that you could cut yourself with
machines in that shop which it was a
house of horrors things that would Bend
and cut metal and twist things and curl
thing and it was just everything was
deadly and you could really [ __ ]
yourself up and every day for lunch we
went to the bar next door and drank and
bet the horses and we'd go back and uh
propose and yeah go back buzzed and and
work giant machines that could rip you
into hammered that's great that's
probably not gonna be the most effective
work no shoddy work a lot of shoddy
workmanship i iack still to this day
wonder if any of the big air
conditioning units I hung above these
ceilings ever just fell down somebody
did you ever do you do what you're doing
obviously I knew what I needed to do to
keep getting paid I did such a minimal
amount of work it was ridiculous you
must know what you were doing wrong too
they you know it was great I worked my
way into getting the small jobs that
they would sent have to send me out for
like a one-off they would have these big
jobs that were developments that were
being built and every day you'd have to
do three houses and it was the same
house every day for like months on end
big tract houses and stuff and I hated
that because people were watching you
yeah there but they would get these jobs
like in the city here and go well
there's this woman she needs a
ventilator hood vent it out of her wall
so just take some metal bend it there I
don't know
and for me I'm like this is nothing I'll
be done in minutes and I will take the
rest of the day huh no call us when
you're done cuz we might send you to
another job yeah whoo that's gonna
happen
would you call immediately when you're
done oh my god
I never Hall every every job that gave
me took all day today everyone were to
origin
cemetary picking weeds and laying pipes
and stuff and my summer job when I was
there are you working oh yeah the first
time we're gonna blacks and they've
taught me how to be lazy on a level
never before weeds like fill up this
giant garbage can with weeds in the
parking lot in the flowerbeds around the
parking lot of like okay
look and I'll just like I guess we gotta
pick weeds all day and as like no we got
a crumpled up newspaper and fill that to
about three cords the way up and then
cover that with weeds and then go to the
back of the parking lot and sleep that
was like wow that's pretty brilliant
genius yeah looks like a full that is
amazing crumpled up it's the [ __ ] people
do when they want to get away with
something oh yeah criminals or anyone
wants to you know work the brilliant
little fix yeah yeah people come up with
there were little forts that were built
to specifically for sleeping on certain
job like plywood and you'd crawl behind
that and put a barrel in front of it and
then take some insulation and put a
blanket over it it was just yeah just a
lot of work to do not a lot of working
dead style like sleeping arranging no no
those weren't union gigs no this was pre
Union before 28 yeah this was before
when I was a scab you know scab action
it was great the scab scab
so his OT be money off the books no no I
like the abbreviation on the box but it
was I there were yes probably
OTB it works you the way Danny
[Laughter]
thought of it that way yeah cell phones
and GPS [ __ ] up every everything I
used to do mom but I was out of it
already I used to have a beeper that
you'd have to call a number but you have
to find a payphone
yeah yes it could be 25 minutes exactly
I don't know that there was a Motorola
radio in the trucks so you could talk on
that face 215 base to 1515
all right go to Grainger and pick up you
just like this sucks this sucks but they
couldn't they couldn't really figure out
where you were I would I would I put a
trailer hitch on the back of my work fan
so I could take the jet ski down to ash
roken on Long Island and during working
hours I would ride my jet ski around
Huntington in Northport you were
supposed to be working I was supposed to
be I was supposed to be working not only
that but like a year later the axle fell
out of the truck from the saltwater
backing it it back in the trailer into
the [ __ ] into the Sun it was the worst
employee ever costing the money ever
it's nice that when you look back in
like wow I think I have to [ __ ] do
that anymore
yeah that's stuck oh I and I looked at
guys that are my age now back then and
I'm like I cannot be that guy I will not
I can't do a row he was doing a job like
that you [ __ ] climbing ladders and
[ __ ] kid at a year hold outside count
the days down through retirement yeah
there's guys on a train you know you
know person 14 weeks 13 days yeah two
hours they counted right down it down
and Colin Ferguson gives him a nice
early one
he was the Long Island Railroad gunman
he was yes yes he was what did you do
before that before you did the 5pi plane
what else do you do before comedy
delivered flowers for like FTD or
something
Pizza attempted temp jobs would you ever
get robbed in the projects well Euler
Peter no I would Montgomery County
Maryland one of the richest counties
yeah okay they had that in DC where they
were like calling people up and then
shooting them either initial raises
right yeah they would shoot people yeah
they were like call delivery and they
lose a fun game to an abandoned house
and kill you
yeah poor a lot of Asian guys who
thought it that way yeah cuz they they
do anything you know there'd be a you
know got like you you'd probably go yeah
go [ __ ] yourself I'm not going there
look at a time anywhere anytime anyway
yeah Pizza guys delivered me they killed
him yeah it happens all over you like I
killed him yeah do you hear about a
delivery guy just getting [ __ ] he's
either robbed and shot Ian wanted a beat
[Laughter]
no no we're gonna have a regular
restaurant and and it sucked because I
was walking a dishwasher and wow what
happened you finally just you and your
partner you [ __ ] through your aprons
at the owner when you get a better game
give you a 5 grand
I'm grand 5 grand yeah no no I had to
clean the jizz exactly like you you know
you're allowed to use soap and water
you'd have to use your tongue it was so
close to touch the plates yeah roscha
and you couldn't there was no way the
gloves didn't work you had to pick
plates up in the gloves never work so
your barehanded and yeah to just grab
these giant bust trays and they're
coming in at an alarming rate during the
rush and you just take your hand and
take whatever slop is on there that
people are eating and look and then just
like throw it into a garbage pail it was
awful did you ever eat off the plates no
really I would have never they gave us
free food there so it was fine but yeah
but believe me if they didn't give me
free food I probably would have found
something in a kosher deli
oh yeah and had to watch the ocean I
threw up boy cause of the smell oh yeah
I got sick when you're saying Jewish
food isn't fair you know I got fired
from McDonald's too cuz I threw up
memory the grease traps yet to scrape
the grease off those do they smell them
horrible you a weak stomach yeah yeah a
little tender stomach guy I walked out a
biology class when they delivered a baby
you movie used to watch the film what I
thought they actually deliver a baby Oh
disgusting yeah you're queasy boy I'm
queasy yeah no sex was it do you like
anal sex no okay queasy what about if
you cut yourself and you bleed do you
get a little Fink no I broke everything
I got I broke a fish bowl on my arm and
I cut an artery
we broke a fish ball yeah it fell we had
this fish ball fall where I dropped it
on your arm yeah I don't know is on like
the cement or on it why were you
carrying a fish bowl to put over his
head for a porno shoot I got hit on the
forehead with a baseball bat and like
cracked my what station we were working
for my mistake yeah yeah using a queasy
with that blood no these stitches which
I yeah yeah and got everything yeah I
fell off a banister broke my arm really
miss banners dish you slide down sure I
slid off my floor on the Little Rascals
[Laughter]
played stickball did you yeah Stu what's
what's what's stupid we throw the ball
against the cement stupid you'd have to
catch it to play handball they dad and
head when he played I'm teasing of
course yeah my friend Marvin one year I
couldn't hit the ball and he was calling
me the strikeout King and every time he
would throw a ball he goes strike out
King and I would swing and miss miss I
got so angry he psyched you out and it
worked
I was the strikeout I shot Marvin in the
face I was so angry did you guys have a
shop in school like metal shop yes there
was a workshop teacher I don't think
probably liability oh you're probably
right there was a woodshop teacher one
of my school who got in trouble fraud
they said allegedly slipping something
into the drink of another teacher oh and
somebody saw it and knocked the drink
over and they fired him that was what I
heard really yeah it was true back then
probably it was one of those dangerous
classes we should throw a wood in the
bandsaw at the table saw house to see if
flying it would fly up right that's when
teachers could smack in the back of the
head
yeah well calling you [ __ ] yeah metal
shop we made screwdrivers that was scary
using like you said though the metal you
made screwdrivers yeah you know they
sell them yeah no reason to project the
teachers can behind you and say show me
show me how fast you can make a hinge
box of hinges he's essential to the war
effort
anything I try to tell him the machines
are being calibrated he's still trying
to fire Oh
there would have been great would you
make those things they were like I was
like a foot long by like six inches high
with like it was gonna nameplate that
was what you'd make it a little chop
you'd carve your name into it just do
that in print shop we had print shop
with a router yeah yeah that's what I
still have I still have a wooden bowl oh
yeah yeah a table I made my mother a
table does she still have it yeah yeah
like a round table umeri yeah that's
pretty cool so you were good at shop I
liked it yeah yeah I liked but we used
to take the BX cables and make billy
clubs that used to do that no BX cable
nice table it's a electrical cable like
the thick thick wire thing yeah and we
used to take the wire out make and take
black electrical tape oh and oh yeah
rope through wrapping around that yeah
going up it's suburbia you never knew
when you'd have a gang fund yeah yeah a
school what's that get any fights in
school we would yeah a rumble yeah we
have fighter jets in the Sharks
there's a guy Vito who used to steal
your pencil cases all the time oh yeah
not not a smart thief [ __ ] pencil
case did you catch him blow on a
security guard on a job site
[Laughter]
dancing that gay club do you think he
knew the jig was up
boy wait he know that was it and those
guys were not they were blabbermouth oh
yeah yeah cigar business the actor yeah
I used to see him on the street in New
York so really out of the back of his
car before after
after the bully yeah no yeah he wrote a
cookbook today yeah yeah and Johnny
cakes killed himself no Johnny cakes
committed suicide the actor yep really
why did he do that I don't know I think
yet he must have been depressed oh man
Johnny cakes I don't remember his real
name but he did commit suicide bet I bet
you know he got typecast there was like
they were like finally I love you Johnny
cakes yeah let's see the real actors
name I don't remember I have a Vincent
Curatola on my show a lot he's a guy it
was Johnny Sack it was great and and
he's great and he we talked about The
Sopranos of course at length and he he
was talking about that whole storyline
he's like yeah I don't know what the
[ __ ] they were doing with that we can't
trust him anymore so weird he had he
shoot all he's separate I know how he
killed himself
I don't know yeah when there's that when
they did that scene where he's he's in
bed with Vito and Vito rolls over like
so his ass is facing him it is facing a
johnnycakes and then he holds him and it
cuts right to a train one of the trains
coming out of a tunnel really yeah so so
gay yeah it was a I'm sure that happens
once in a while yeah usually you [ __ ]
thirty just caught it's a joke it's a
joke what do you got no no it's a job
whose dress yeah there he is he's
dressed in the
doodle leather-like your head a minute
boys are they dancing and they kind of
go in there too either just walking
collecting money money from the
bartender they're not happy I think with
the atmosphere oh no they don't like
being there these two mob guys are not
pleased everyone's dressed in vests with
cowboy hats and I chose DJed in New York
how was it I didn't know it was a gay
bar when I went in then when did it
girls show up seriously a buddy of mine
said you want to work in his bar they
pay good money all you need to do is
walk and rent you with your records you
know they got the turntables all there
yeah great was on it was in New York on
the Lower East Side how could you not
see you oh so what happened you're
working in there the open vests yeah
cruising you know just went in there I
used to wear a black shirt no bowtie did
they love you what's that did they love
you there yeah and it was all fast music
they don't dance to slow music it was
well well that looks really silly you
don't see to the village peoples
sometimes when we touch one [ __ ]
poppers and club music yeah same thing
with singles dances I used to deejay
singles dances and what's that just I
guess a bunch of singles yeah it was
Jewish American singles on the Jewish
ones yeah yeah and girls would walk up
there guys so what do you do the guys
wanted slow music so they could ladies
choice
those Jew globes against your chest
music why so they could just so they
wouldn't have to do it close enough to
dance slow sounds like a wonderful time
yeah of people just avoiding each other
I'll do any I did a lesbian dance once
yeah yeah they helped me with the
speaker's ooh and nice people all right
powerful people yeah yeah dance to
helped you with the speakers all because
they were very you know brawny women
yeah there were nice people bunch of
brawny gal yeah and they tipped well
they did huh yeah at the cash you know
jiae's have a lot of money because they
never spent money on anything or on
their kids these are obtained so you're
saving a big in for a long time it was
you know they just had money to spend
their goods yeah that's interesting take
DJ a biker wedding once really you know
it was a lot of Marshall Tucker and 38
special brothers I bet Allman Brothers
right yeah don't play that disco crap no
sir
now when you age eight another word for
the disco what they call it the n-word
oh boy really I don't even have that
music I said well then we're crap
whether they say don't play any of that
n-word that music now did you say I
don't appreciate that term you play
Sweet Home Alabama I played that yeah I
played fire on the mountain I also
played Black Sabbath the Sabbath
yeah well that's you you do it all yeah
do you still use a vinyl wear or to use
what digital it all digital right I'm a
digital DJ yeah yeah so that's kind of
easy yeah eight seconds you hit a button
and it just plays well no it's a lot
more than that you can't know what is
crowd you all you have to know what
they're gonna read the crowd crowd see
what they're reacting to own boy really
is putting too much thought into this
well you have to you could literally say
what kind of event is it pre set up the
playlist hit go and never have to touch
another thing until you're leaving no
they would think it's too easy I'm
usually standing behind their dances
well you could do that ideally bacon do
you get embarrassed
no of course dude you cheesy like
catchphrases to get everybody dancing
and everybody is they're not good though
cuz you're not good you know get those
cuts off the chairs like you can't use
this anymore we don't like it I might
not be here for a long time but we're
here for a good time I use that one well
that's that's a good one get those cuts
off the chairs
I don't like this after I do a slow
dance I always go make sure you give
that person a nice big hug and a kiss
pause and please introduce yourself oh
yeah usually at a wedding
yeah let's get all those single ladies
on the dance floor and those ladies who
wish they were single oh and then they
all go let's have a nice round of
applause as we invite the best man up
for the toast there's a lot of good men
in here but he's the best man but that's
not really good well you get it there's
a lot of good men in here but he's the
best man why would you say he's the best
man again of all the other men yeah but
why aren't they all best man I don't
understand they're good but he's the
best oh because he's the best man at the
wedding I can't Andra it's a play on
words want to kill yourself you big
props out too don't you
you know like oops I remember at the
party you DJed at my house yes we had
done it so given the same request as you
worked the biker rally about the music
yeah the cops came and but that was fine
then they left and you brought out the
hula hoops why the hoops why not all
right it's run to the party it's here I
brought it not when the cops were there
yeah you did yeah and they were fine
with hula hoops
yeah it's Rosland it's not really that
crazy of town a hand sir is that true
Travis yeah just hold me tell him some
handsome Rob's thinking about hiring
Dennis for his wedding Oh we'll have to
talk that means if Rob can't afford it
he gets Denny I thought he was like 16 I
didn't know he's getting married
yeah Mary when's the wedding I oughta
stent oh okay they should all just Rob
cheese's I thought he was that I haven't
gotten the invitation yet yeah no it's a
well we're sending him out after the new
year no how do you uh 26 26 yeah I guess
it's like Ralph Macchio yes I can play
[ __ ] 15 yeah so was Ukraine kick
that's get all the older Asian gentlemen
to rub your leg
it's tender how long how long have been
engaged we got engaged in July how old
are you 26 26 how long have you known
her before you were engaged we've been
going out for over four years going
steady Oh what was his name
oh [ __ ] do you use that at any of your
gigs same-sex weddings 200 you have yeah
there are a lot of fun a lot of fun
don't seem like they'd be the most fun
on a great they'd be the most like no
stop you should just go up and start
reading Scripture today and saying how
they're gonna burn in hell ever since I
did a Jehovah party they don't have part
it was not it was around I don't even
know what they called it a holiday party
their playlist was just silence yeah
yeah and I was playing a song called so
many men so little time and that's the
gay wedding so I and it's raining men
and they told me do not play any music
like that
disco music has roots in the homosexual
community oh did they use the f-word for
that don't play any of that f-word
hahahaha
no but they're a fun bunch they were
yeah they weren't a fun bunch Manson's
followers what a fun bunch acally you
know squeaky Fromme buddy your ass on a
first date what a trooper Oh ginger
[ __ ] on earth anybody that will slice a
baby out will suck your dick immediately
pros and cons Oh
ironically while drinking a cup of
Folgers bon voyage yeah Charlie thanks
for let him out what if they ever let
him out I mean he was never not crazy
right yeah but don't you think if they
let him out like even 20 years ago for
him to be like 63 that he would have
like he's nuts and everything but he's
just like an another old nut that you'd
see out on the street yeah you wouldn't
go I don't think he would have killed
anyone else
now I would have put them up anyone else
he couldn't have the power to kill you
know sometimes somebody would have given
a place man to live in yeah it's gotten
a job in a supermarket and then extras
name in the ceiling and hung him sent
hung himself call him a Charlotte he had
some kind of connection with the Dennis
Wilson of the Beach Boys yeah really
yeah he did
yeah Madsen was hanging out he's trying
to play his music yeah yeah yeah I think
he wrote songs with him possibly your
man Dennis Wilson I think lived at his
place yeah they were friends and I think
he wanted him to help with his uh didn't
Dennis mom I don't remember what the
Dennis was more of a connection to that
house too
wasn't I didn't he go there or send them
there thinking Dennis Wilson was going
to be home and my kink I think that was
a house Dennis Wilson had had right and
Manson was mad that he warned with his
music or something I got the wrong
address
it's at my friend's place in LA yeah
people always drive past [ __ ] yeah I
don't remember if that was uh Dennis
Wilson didn't want to help him or
something or I don't remember what it
was I'm not sure the songs weren't good
they why have you here it
Charles Manson songs and I want to hear
snow cover I'm like musicians be like
let me make this a little I know garbage
dump garbage dump was one of his songs
he just talks to my garbage dump garbage
done yeah that's fine Manson's music
yeah good stuff but don't look up
Maryland because Maryland's a rocker I
say [ __ ] [ __ ] I know I love that song
how about my world Oh
[Music]
my brother's starting to didi dum dee
dum doo doo dodoo dodoo I don't care if
she's pregnant save they would have just
given him some kind of a singing career
mister maybe he would have been cold
between him and Hitler you'd have a few
bad records and a few bad paintings is
six million and eight alive people
[Music]
dee dee really he's got that folky a
thing like that Joan Baez Joan Baez for
me I hide for that stand I love diamonds
and Russia when I think but Anthony
[ __ ] erected I would listen that's
all the time and he said something like
she sounds like she's singing to a fan
yeah folk singer tremolo thing the song
is amazing it's amazing song it's a love
song to Bob Dylan that she wrote that's
it
yeah yes Stan Joan Baez you know like
this know San Francisco she sings she
bit of a voice it's kind of music they
played one on for wine and cheese here
this this is the beginning of an tyfa
all this [ __ ] just beginning all the PC
[ __ ] we put up with no she's just
saying a nice song about oh [ __ ] her one
of those big 70s bushes that's it that's
a plus Judas Priest covered this really
they did their own version of it without
certain specifics about you said my
poetry with I see this like this stuff
they took out yeah you know like this my
poetry it's just that it's him pure
hippie [ __ ] that I have no [ __ ] use
for my [ __ ] smells like bloody gums
you say so anything worse than the smell
of bleeding gums they weren't very
hygienic turn it down professional
coming why'd you hit Nick yeah that
[ __ ] chick comes out all the time
around the house you know going man what
are you coming on chip Aires Vedanti was
great well you come on
no it's not that I won't come on watch
come on tomorrow night what are you
doing 6:30 p.m. on Comedy Cellar I'm on
to be two of us yeah it would be fun and
what you doin tomorrow night yeah 6:30
p.m.
I got jury duty tomorrow I'll be done by
that are you sure yeah howdy God is
anyone it's tough to get out of it yeah
Ida sent something back you don't always
get their notices we just got a mail and
if you gotta go you gotta go you used to
get out of it years ago just tell ya I'm
in the media the guy knew who I was
maybe you can get out of it
not now and booted me right out you know
who I was and just said yeah you don't
have to you gotta wait it's forever and
so you get into the room where they go
now it was fast I got checking you in
yeah I had I had a I'll tell you
something guns are a great thing for
camaraderie with people with other guns
because I I was carrying my gun and
you're not allowed to have a gun in
court no so at the door you tell him I
have a firearm and they voucher it and
lock it up for you but while they're
doing it they start talking to you and
it's all like good old boy buddy gun
talk and then before you know he's like
all right sit here don't worry about it
I'll get get [ __ ] out of here that
was it
what he says to you and in his mind he's
like alright this psycho brought a gun
into court decision on someone's life I
was i I leak I did everything
legally what you were supposed to do I
actually had a gun at the Neil Diamond
show at the in Brooklyn well at the
Barclays Center why well cuz I was
carrying my gun that's you know what you
do know I went to the guy diamond show
just in case he's not on just in case
yes Neil Diamond Jessica sigh I don't
like the way he's singing Casey doesn't
do a girl you'll be a woman soon yeah
yeah
I am I said start [ __ ] busting some
caps yo I do love you know I do love
Neil Diamond Neil Diamond's great
what solitary man might be my favorite
oh that's a good one then again Kentucky
woman is good that's a good Johnny Cash
a solitary man was great I don't know
that one when he did all the American
covers I love those did he cover
solitary man huh we hear that I didn't
know he covered that [ __ ] Johnny Johnny
Cash yeah one of my favorite episodes of
Columbo with Johnny Cash Johnny Cash
episode there was a channel harder yeah
it kills his own wife really yes she was
being a blue lippy where's the China
cash cover no the Johnny Cash was you
what are you doing
he's like I saw the light
so the Ludd it was the the song in
Calamba scream was it yeah
yeah oh this is Neil done I know it is
we asked for Johnny Cash yeah
eight times no no no he just played a
piece of that that's a good that is they
never told you that you could work with
men all right this is Johnny Johnny Cash
[Music]
this after the strokes I don't like this
as much as no diamonds Neil Diamond's is
so peppy and up happy and peppy and
bursting with doo-doo-doo-doo I like
okay Johnny Cash just decided like I'm
gonna do everyone else's [ __ ] and
there's nothing you can do about it well
Rick room and I four albums four albums
of covers Rick Rubin I think you know
that and they're great though they're
great heart is better than I know rusty
cage is better so you know like he's
rusty I don't like like Johnny Cage
doing covers of the songs that I enjoyed
listening to in the 90s
I'm waiting to yelling a dancing queen
young and sweet homeless 17 like he's
singing everything [ __ ] stop I like it
well he did stop how about 13 you ever
hear that song no come on 13 my Johnny I
think Danzig wrote it yeah dan glenn
danzig wrote it and it might have been
for Johnny Cash and signal I don't know
he did it
you never heard 13 no some shock you
haven't
[Laughter]
you never heard this not really great
song I don't know if Danzig sang this
first yeah these are all songs that
could be played during the credits in a
movie that's what they sound like you
don't love this - western cross afire
[Laughter]
yeah some of the old Johnny Cash is
pretty good like a stile just yet but he
was never really one of my big favor
God's gonna cut you down that's a great
so why did you see the video for it who
used to come out to that UFC fighter
used to come out to that I mean he might
not use not it might have been yeah no
nothing like that he did the video after
he died he had all these all these crazy
celebrities were in it he didn't do the
video obviously was dead but you didn't
miss my song Tom what's-his-name used to
sing she's late Tom Tom Jones used to
sing this now that's a vocalist yes he
was still is but not as good as used Tom
Jones yeah what is this guy I don't know
just some dude you saw the video for
this oh my god who cares
oh it's [ __ ] what's-his-name yeah yeah
yeah and he's got all these weird
celebrities just making cameos in it
it's on yeah it's a bizarre video people
singing along with it
gun Campbell eating a workbook David
Cassidy's singing into a turnip
I think he's like at death's door
what does dementia do was it from
drinking or no just yo yeah Oh what
about an Malcolm young guy Angus his
brother one of the founders of ac/dc
woke up and bombed this morning come on
github walk up and bomb the smart thing
that everybody I think I love you as a
[ __ ] amazing great song yeah
is it dementia what is with these guys
why does dementia kill you and again
Malcolm young died 67 or 64 of dementia
I think when you have it normal things
they take a knife instead of slicing
bread I think if you been if your
dementia is because you've been abusing
yourself with drugs and alcohol for so
long I think your body is shot what was
David Cassidy a slave to the drink I
think he was much like a jack his dad
who was also in a great episode of
Columbo Jack Cassidy died no oh he was
smoking in bed yeah fire will you wake
up he was I think he was intoxicated is
why here yeah Jack Cassidy sexuality
I'll he's bisexual okay he was that's
what killed him yeah he yeah he was very
jealous of his sons success with the
Partridge families and with music yeah
he was married to was shirley jones he
had a good act for a little while Jack
Cassidy who's jealous
David David wanted to do rock he didn't
want it right those poppy songs from The
Partridge Family he was on the cover of
Tiger Beat like I remember the Bay City
Rollers were beyond and I used to love
Tiger
then there was team beat they would once
in a while have kiss but when they
didn't have kiss I didn't buy them yeah
best magazines to jerk off to highlight
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes
song to a vagina good stuff Wow these
are actually to dance to his later work
screams of a begging woman yeah
[Music]
that sums it up in one big
not the best lyrics no no not one of
those iam his hits here we go
he really was terrible at the guitar
[Music]
this is like nice garbage dump Oh
garbage dump heavy here Johnny Cash's
version of garbage dump that's great you
know you do I guarantee you musicians
this whole week on concerts are gonna
play like this song yeah but it's a
really weird gotta pay a tribute to it's
like how about a guy who raped an infant
why don't you play one of his songs
there's a [ __ ] hunk of garbage wait
wait oh you know what Danny I apologize
I put on 2 not 3 sorry but no no my
fault you'll get used to it I know I
know I'm it's six months board up like
it says I'm sorry Denny uh
that's Sam's mic it's all right it's
part of me never once I'm turned on yeah
what I just read a tweet from Sam saying
he was it he died works at WWE knees
flying home he usually comes back but he
just couldn't oh by the way thank you
chip person chip Falcone I tweeted that
anyways thank you the chip mashups yeah
I met him by the way Tefft chipper said
he's a big Twitter guy for our show like
he just Twitter's a lot of stuff and
what like he will absolutely be arrested
with a woman's head in a bowling bag no
no there's no test Jew person we don't
know who that is person to person what
do you do impressions no it's it's for
hairy guys
oh yeah no I don't actually check I'm
wondering if you added pressure that's
why I'm asking
yeah I don't do Ari Shaffir it's a theft
pattern down there was the tempers and
he change it to Toshi I think sorry why
did it change it you know why tempt us
yeah
funny part of the whole thing these are
a picture of me and him wait on stage -
no go - they go to media or something I
want to see if he tweeted the picture of
me and him look at how big this guy is
[Laughter]
yeah that's really happy I never had a
run-in with him
show your face he wouldn't they yeah
yeah right I'll kick your ass
wow he is a big gentleman he's a burly
boy yeah look at the hands out look at
the [ __ ] dick Peters on that kid
Jesus Christ he's probably accidentally
killed children yeah I was happy I was
just holding him he's a big-headed
fellow - ham you just would not fare
well in prison why wouldn't I I don't
know you look like a slight gentleman
there next to a big giant make him laugh
does that work does that work in prison
I know it works in school keep their
mind off the booty mr. prior to that
well yeah yeah what Danny that move down
move it down
no the up that fella he looks like that
gentleman I couldn't remember his
nowhere go Anthony try to fall go which
way up down right there hold it yes that
guy he looked like he did yeah Anthony
are talking like he could have said
Andre the Giant I would have said oh my
god his name I forgot his
I do good on ship doesn't on a giant
impression so Falkenberg like small
children
sounds like Luke for right now this is
the worst 35 foot taller buildings hey
did you watch that that night of too
many stars on HBO it was a charity for
autism no I didn't it was so [ __ ] bad
was it
Jon Stewart hosted it was like true
comics and the rest of just actors and
actresses yeah Louie was supposed to be
on it after he got in trouble [ __ ] uh
Bonnie McFarlane tweeted night of just
the right amount of stars because they
said it was removed not too many stars
great the best is all the subway
platform ads and have them on there yeah
they're all graffiti oh yeah yeah I'm
sure Oh any list a night what does that
say a night of a list sure per for
comedians who a list comics Jon Stewart
unless skipped over Robert DeNiro
my pal your pal Bobby DeNiro Bobby D but
who ever got from the 90s named Billy
Crystal Oh God Ben Stiller John Oliver
biggest it was but it was terrible
they have Chris Rock up there they had
him doing a bit for way too long that
wasn't funny at all
it was uh Chris Rock's gonna read
people's minds in the audience
logistically it was a disaster they
couldn't get [ __ ] straight and then was
it just wasn't yeah
it was completely left that's that's
what yeah it was live and then but there
was one part there was an autistic woman
who does a talk-show she does a
talk-show but she can't talk or anything
she just oh wow it's like she she pre
records the questions with the you know
the whole well I need to know what you
think
with that hotel she types it in the
computer voice thing she types it in but
it went horribly run the promo film a
plate of it was great you're watching on
oh my god this this woman's kind of
sitting there you can't even tell you
would look at her like she knows nothing
and this brilliance is coming out of her
so they put this desk on the stage and a
little microphone and Colbert comes out
and she's gonna interview Stephen
Colbert right there on the on the stage
so she's looking all weird and and then
she just gets up off the chair and
starts looking at stuff on the floor
apparently they had launched some some
gold confetti and it was on the stage
and that was it that was that sort
counting they could she couldn't get
back on track way she's kept looking at
the gold stuff she would not look at if
she got up and started picking them up
on the floor she couldn't that's great
it was so uncomfortable there's just
kind of looking and then the audience is
let and then the the roots the band it
was Ruth they just start but didn't win
when playing and they put the camera on
them while they just assured her oh hey
oh wow I was cringing watching this know
yeah I want to see that really
uncomfortable who was in at night of too
many star cold it was Stephen Colbert
and a woman with autism Cabiria autism
and then they had that injury Abrams
like Abrams on camera was there yeah and
again a horrible bit what did Bob say I
I missed the Bob De Niro I would love to
have seen that
oh is this a missus it where's this the
whole showing around an important cause
not as left and right not as blue and
red with people just now finding out
that Puerto Ricans are Americans
what the [ __ ] and there's teeth there's
cursing in front of young children with
autism in the crowd I don't mind that I
don't care either let me see the you
can't find her
where's the Colbert one she's oh that
might be it the bots on the this was
five minutes dammit no now it was toward
the middle yeah somewhere it towards the
middle of the functional [ __ ] yeah it
was I wish you I wish you could find it
it's so uncomfortable yeah maybe she's
got nervous in the air out no no I
they say she wants to be the first talk
show host that doesn't speak what's your
show really didn't oh yeah there she is
but she's older now no no this is that
playing some some video of her as a kid
but you can't skip over that
what's Jesus he's like a minute fifty
into that a minute fifty into that into
this the Georgia right yeah so that was
her as a kid and she's off you know
[ __ ] up and stuff and I want to say
kids still gave her some stupid the
parents give her stupid haircut that's
kind of nice she had this little talk
show and you get this adorable blanket
no this is uh this is her as a kid yeah
no I mean everything she has a talk yeah
then she has a talkshow cystic children
who's cute as [ __ ] where she doesn't
talk though once they get a little older
though oh my god yeah I want to see the
toy what happened no that was know that
that's afterwards Oh what did they
[ __ ] cut the whole part out where
she's like you can't maybe they're not
putting it online yeah well she cheesed
out they cut the whole thing out what
the [ __ ] poor gals embarrassed you can't
YouTube Corey Fleshman CW site maybe
that you have it on regular YouTube yeah
you don't go to eat W to find the
humiliating moment they might not like
that um flush you just do Colbert from
knighted or Carla yeah okay maybe you
got it she's cute
that's art well her teeth look has been
chewing lock washers
all right so she isn't the best teeth I
know what happens I've noticed on this
show a lot of autistic people their
teeth aren't very good yeah I guess it's
hard this show say they probably pulled
it off everything someone's probably got
it yeah someone would have to but I bet
they they go around and go yeah we can't
embarrass her you gotta order go to the
dark web and order bad also can I get
that cory gunz drugs right pay for it
with bitcoins and you'll get it do you
have Bitcoin no you know how to use I
don't know anything about that when I
robbing people they suddenly is just
their accounts gone but like they keep
saying like if you're just bought a
hundred dollars like four years ago
you'd be a millionaire
yeah and they could keep saying that you
can sell them yeah it's crazy they're up
to like thousands and thousands now yeah
I have no how do you spend part of a
Bitcoin on yeah you do it over a
computer transaction or no no no but I
mean like how do you okay yeah right
fraction I don't make no sense
oh good very hurt my [ __ ] teeth
showing you now they're no they're not
right whatever enough I didn't watch it
I saw part of it on I was doing a gig I
was a place called the jukebox comedy
club which I actually loved in Peoria
Illinois it was brutal who's so hot I
mean so I'll be so cool icy icy cold
really but uh it was like that [ __ ]
Illinois cold but there was a fun gig
yeah I enjoyed it a lot yeah a couple of
years ago they were at the same autistic
charity they had the little kid girl
piano player that comes out at the end
and and does the finale
she good and yeah she's really good but
they they brought her back this year and
boy did she eat a lot she's a big fatty
yeah look I'm just treating everyone
equally I call all the time
Travis he found it yeah Rob's Rob
sending it to Anthony right now it's a
YouTube clip so Rob is good he's very
good he's very handsome
no one's ever mention that but
how did he find it he found it on
YouTube you found the entire thing on
the HBO YouTube did we not look for that
in this room Anthony I told my Ghana HBO
no I did not I figured it'd be on
YouTube for some reason Carly Fleischman
that's a big event
now look she's just I don't buy this at
all HBO enticed me to come on this show
by promising me and huge celebrities
such as Oprah or Ellen DeGeneres to
interview but all that I get is this guy
unfortunately I welcome that guest for
tonight king of late-night Stephen
Colbert now she's supposed to like does
she pre type you these questions uh yeah
now she's distracted yeah so she's
bending that under the desk Emily
Litella thank you very much
and now she just in her mouth remember
that walking around I think are
wonderful now he's trying to read here
because I care about people more than
they do
he's trying schoo bears trying to sound
like this oh yeah no hands coming out
now they just clap that was on the stage
they didn't they didn't shoot it then
stuff that was on the floor yeah yeah
they I don't mind that your fat your ice
is so embarrassing but that's what it is
you prop you up there so you can feel
bad for Ryan that's what I try to do now
the roots play and and they go to them
maybe she's all nervous well they beat
her off the stage nervous Nellie you
remember the Jerry Lewis telethon they
always used to oh yeah look at me I'm
walking that was ice I think look at me
I'm walking was for the cerebral palsy
telethon with um yeah yeah I think yeah
I can't do it well no you this is my sad
able to and then she's still not able to
I don't like the whole thing I do I
can't I don't buy the whole thing I
don't buy the cheese programming the
[ __ ] questions in I don't I think
she's just sitting there and someone
else put the questions in yeah and and
of course yeah she may enter them she
may pre enter them a lot so somebody
from the like the production goes out
there was like wait she's not is she
supposed to be immediately a guy came
out yeah he saw that she was biko bears
trying to salvage it's just awkward ride
because I care about people more than me
and people like alright well laughing
but we're watching this clip Travis I
don't know Rob said that they brought
her back out of the end yeah at the end
they brought her up tonight's guest on
the Carly Fleischman show I'm here with
Carly Fleischman and she's like cleaning
her face like a cat she's licking her
hand and rubbing her face yeah that's
crazy
well we just started we just started the
interview and Carly got distracted and I
wanted you to know that Carly's
distraction has nothing to do with her
autism it has everything to do with
their her OCD oh I really want to do
this interview with Carly I got a peek
at her questions and this is honest to
god that was gonna be a real interview
and we're gonna do it in the future and
I looked at the questions they're
hilarious and she wrote all of them so
Carly I don't believe it I'm sorry I
don't believe she wrote anything oh
you're such a cynic haha she's walking
back and forth
I don't light any nervous though she's
never been in front of all these people
I think she has been I get nervous in
front of people and I'm a start he's
like they're hilarious she wrote him to
herself I swear but on this episode of
Teller's [ __ ] I like the Colbert's a
dressing I like that he's actually yeah
and then Jon Stewart blames himself for
the whole thing so it's like this whole
trifecta of [ __ ] because he said
somebody decided to fire the cannon with
the confetti and it came down and he
goes and that person is who's at fault
here and that person was big I'm an
[ __ ] so he takes the blame for it but
they should have let the autistic take
the blame
do with that she's fine it's just
severely OCD that's way better that did
seem a little OCD picking [ __ ] up
counting it how about your [ __ ] proud
I've watched that goddamn guy on on
goddamn America's Got Talent
Howie Mandel he's got OCD he does he's
actually he's able to [ __ ] watch you
know for a half hour I just think it's I
just think Anthony's hilarious [ __ ]
those questions nothing that they could
prove that she wrote those it was like
oh they promised me big stars but I got
Stephen Colbert instead haha that's
funny and then she gets up and starts
eating the [ __ ] floor we're going to
get a real DJ we have a good time we
have a good time and I've been
complimented because people say you know
you talk to them and you make sure their
haven't sure I like that they addressed
it at the end like they didn't just
pretend it didn't happen like this is
what happens they gloss over she at
least HBO something her out look she got
she she got distracted on CD they at
least had told you what it was I think I
felt seating my ass let's a copy a
combination I mean I just liked it they
dressed it and Colbert I thought was
nice about what are you gonna do yeah
yeah yeah autistic up if you want test
if you grow up like you expect you to do
nothing and then you get a talk show
you're doing something and then all of a
sudden people man you can't do it on the
life isn't good on live HBO poor girl
panic and fell apart yeah radio show and
I don't know you know 20 years in the
business I know how to do deaf radio
[Laughter]
[Applause]
some people were to take words very
literally yes I don't know what she has
I don't her what to I don't know what
kind of autism it I think there's people
that are highly their function autistic
with the words become very low bow yeah
even Seinfeld said that when he remember
when Seinfeld said he was on the
spectrum and then he came back instead
he was it but he goes I take words very
literally like that was why he thought
he was yeah like there's something with
I certainly recognize that he can that
he does it I think like yeah like if
somebody ever like oh yeah you'll be
late like that instead of going yeah I
will be like being knowing you're being
sarcastic oh no I won't be I don't I
don't like the fact that autism is a
label that could be put on somebody that
can say like yeah well I'm diagnosed on
the spectrum ought to and and be
completely fine and the other end is
blithering idiot yeah and it's the same
thing but maybe there's just no that's
really called a spectrum there's just
didn't you know spectrum yeah there's
different yeah yeah excuse for been
doing that on on his show and it's
[ __ ] hilarious he's going out with
this woman who has a son and she keeps
saying he's got autism he's on the
spectrum and he's just the nastiest
little [ __ ] kid to Larry and Larry is
like I don't think he has autism
[ __ ] hilarious that that the season
started slow and it's now [ __ ] great
against it start slow I gave it a stir
episode yes is not good it what it
wasn't the first couple episodes weren't
good but he's like he does not give a
[ __ ] about offending anybody yeah and I
love that pretty good he's making fun of
the kid who's just an [ __ ] too
she does like maybe he's just an [ __ ]
it's just an [ __ ] to me okay so he
doesn't really buy the spectrum thing
I'm not I don't buy that you can be have
something and it could be like nothing
really or it could be you can't even
function as a person there's people who
are [ __ ] and it's profoundly like
profoundly being people who can't do
anything and then there's [ __ ]
people who can kind of go work at
McDonald's like you get [ __ ] you know
those big jobs for people that yeah I I
get apples are being [ __ ] like some
people can't do anything and they can't
feed themselves and as young people go
out and get a little job on a plane
can't defend himself [ __ ] shots
fired
Oh oh my god what's Howard think about
that really billions of dollars yeah -
Eagles talk about it yep let's do that
gloves are off yep they should be well
he wants to have you all to talk what no
no no not how and I [ __ ] don't give a
[ __ ] about you Joel I said we weren't
them we didn't care whatever